[Musique]
18 janvier il fait moins 25 à boppard et
on s'en vient jardiner leur froid dehors
pis ça nous manque de mettre les mains
dans la terre donc là c'est l'occase
s'occuper pendant l'hiver
à la verticale à l'horizontale de 50 à
plus de 1000 $ les jardins d'intérieur
sont multiples et populaire on a choisi
trois modèles compacts clés en main
parmi les modèles les plus économiques
et un système complètement fait maison y
en a trois qui sont une culture qu'on
appelle hydroponique donc avec une
solution vraiment de à base d'os que de
l'eau avec des nutriments dedans puis le
dernier c'est plus une culture classique
en terreau
des herbes et du feuillage ferait tout
l'hiver c'est ce qu'on va tenter de
faire pousser avec notre expert en
agriculture urbaine alors on va tester
du basilic on va tester de la roquette à
la bette à carde arc en ciel et puis le
dernier c'est lequel
[Musique]
une fois que l'on intègre de l'eau dans
le réservoir on a juste à le brancher
on a des fois des éléments connectés les
uns avec les autres par exemple juste la
lumière connectés mais c'est très simple
c'est très bien expliqué aussi dans
l'est dans les manuels ce qu'il est
peut-être un petit peu moins quand on
fait un kit fait maison parce qu'ils
font un tout petit peu plus de
connaissances
les semences pour ces trois machines
sont déjà été gré dans des capsules avec
substrat la bête à cornes à caen seul
avantage des ensembles prêts à semer
c'est l'éclairage qui est fourni avec
chaque modèle une minuterie intégré
permet de garder allumer les lampes et
pour une durée recommandée de 14 à 16
heures quotidiennement on s'est rendu
compte que par exemple une langue qui
était vraiment beaucoup plus étroite
allez avoir un rayonnement beaucoup
moins large logiquement que une cale et
avoir vraiment une lampe qui allait être
conçu de telle sorte que l éclair d'une
manière beaucoup plus homogène et puis
beaucoup plus large puis le résultat a
été que c'était plus facile pour les
plantes d'aller chercher la lumière dans
ce cas là il ya un aspect aussi qui est
pas à négliger c'est la finesse avec
laquelle on peut monter la lampe au fur
et à mesure c'est d'ailleurs quelque
chose qui est pas proposée avec le clip
jam qui était peut-être un de ses
défauts mais par contre les autres on
peut ajuster donc les canes gros et
aérogares dit nous on est capable
d'ajuster le niveau de la langue ce qui
est logique parce qu'on va suer
finalement la progression de la plante
bien montée bien branché biais ce b le
travail ne s'arrête pas là il faut
s'assurer que dans nos réservoirs d'eau
on a toujours de l'eau puis plus la
plante va croître on va pousser plus
elle va à consommer de l'eau donc ça va
arriver assez vite que tous les jours il
va falloir rajouter de l'eau dans le
réservoir surtout cette étape lol pour y
aller vraiment tous les jours on parie
ci remplit un petit indicateur à
l'intérieur qui nous dit quand c'est
plein et voilà
c'est dans ce laboratoire installé au
sous sol de sa maison afin de mieux
contrôler équitablement la lumière pour
chacune des machines que vincent a
expérimenté cette nouvelle technologie
de jardinage dont vous les avez isolé
c'est ça exactement elles ont tous et
sont tous isolés mais en maintenant
voilà une respiration une aération puis
une température constante également dans
le lieu où ça a été testé tous les jours
où les deux jours je venais fermé 1 mais
relever pour voir la croissance la
présence éventuelle de maladie mais on
va aussi retrouver pour certains d'entre
eux une petite bouteille de fertilisants
avec une notice sas a rajouté aux deux
semaines donc il ya certes un kit qui
propose un petit rappel pour dire
attention tu as oublié de mettre ton
fertilisants puis d'autres qu'elle ne
propose pas donc c'est un petit peu ça
qu'on a comparé aussi le côté pratique
de ces machines pour faire en sorte que
finalement ça s'intègre dans un
quotidien qui est déjà beaucoup chargé
dans nos vies d'adultes la neuf semaines
plus tard 23 mars on y venu récolter
s'était tant que vous veniez parce que
là il faut vraiment qu'on récolte les
plantes ont atteint leur maximum les
feuilles sont en train de toucher les
lumières donc là ça commence à brûler il
est vraiment temps qu'on fasse notre
école depuis qu'on passe à la cuisine on
a vu vraiment des grandes différences
dans la croissance des plants et puis la
quantité des récoltes il ya différents
facteurs par rapport à ça qu'ils ont
influé sur sur ça mais l'un des
principaux c'est probablement justement
la lumière donc la quantité de lumière
puis la manière dont elle est desservie
finalement sur les plans mais aussi la
capacité du réservoir donc la quantité
d'eau finalement qui est disponible pour
les racines ce qui va donner aussi
peut-être plus d espace là aux racines
pour aller chercher leurs nutriments
puisse se déployer
et là c'est vraiment aérogare dengue qui
va se démarquer par rapport à ça parce
qu'ils offrent une justement une lumière
plus large et un réservoir plus grand
je regarde celui là ici ça c'est ce que
vous avez fabriqué maison effectivement
donc là on est vraiment sur un petit
plateau de culture et du terreau dedans
donc c'est le seul qui arrive de la
terre les autres sont avec de l'eau est
ici c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui reste dix
petits alors ici en fait puis c'est
pareil pour toute l'équipe que j'ai
testé on a démarré des cultures de
brassica c'est donc comme étant duquel
de la requête des les choux mais en fait
dans aucun des kits ça n'a fonctionné
gérer peut-être une préférence pour
aeroguard
ceci dit j'ai aussi beaucoup apprécié
mais jo a déjà parce que le produit
aussi offert en deux langues donc
c'était quand même plus facile pour
suivre les indications pour pré
m'orienter dans les cultures de plantes
et puis après le kit fait maison a quand
même ses avantages aussi parce qu'il
permet à près de réutiliser tous
matériels là pour éventuellement partir
s'est soumis
pourquoi l'aérogare donne est l'appareil
le plus intéressant ça va être la
lumière
l'ajustement de sa lumière la quantité
qu'offre son réservoir ça va quand même
être son prix je pense qu'il est quand
même souvent spéciale en tout cas nous
en comparant s'est rendu compte que
c'était 7 économique la grande diversité
des variétés de plantes proposées
le résultat obtenu
c'est pas forcément une démarche qui
vise à l'autonomie alimentaire avec un
kit on va pas remplir notre garde-manger
où notre frigo mais c'est très
sympathique de pouvoir alors mettre les
mains là terre c'est pas le bon terme
ici mais pouvoir avoir la main verte
avec ses plantes l'appui de devenir un
petit peu jardinier